[DRAMATIC MUSIC] I'M LEAVING
I'M GONE
NO MORE!
[music change] for...a week. I'm going to the UK.
This Wednesday, I'll be flying out to the UK to join Jack and Felix for a charity livestream for (RED).
And if you don't know about (RED), they're an organization that
is trying to fight AIDS, and hopefully eliminate it forever.
So we're going to be raising money for them through our Charity Cringemas!
which I-I don't exactly know what we're going to be doing, but judging by the name
pretty much the same thing we always do in all of our videos. Cringe uncontrollably.
Or make you guys cringe.
That's this upcoming week and I'll talk more about that later in next week's vlog
but this past week...
was incredible!
If you guys have been seeing some snippets, and some hints around here and there,
you guys don't even know the half of it.
Bob and Wade came into town and from the second they got here, from the second they left, we were non-stop making videos.
Li-uh like we pretty much recorded nineteen videos worth of content.
MAYBE MORE depending on how these videos turn out because some of 'em,
we were just messing around and we don't have any idea how it's going to go,
but a lot of them were really fun experiences!
Like Thursday last week, we went out and we hit three different parks,
And we did three different videos with you guys in these parks just having fun, playing games, and just being ridiculous.
The first one that came out was actually the last one we did which was Quick, draw!
[laugh] And that was just super fun because we were playing Pictionary in front of a big crowd of you guys!
And it was just fun all around because we all took turns doing things,
well, I mean, we took turns, you guys took turns, and I was subjected to either looking like a fool...
or looking like an asshole.
And-and it's just really fun to play games with you guys, and just hang out with you guys,
and make these videos that combine the games that I play- you know, here in my studio, quote unquote, "Studio", my "second bedroom"
And uh, you know, combined that with going out and meeting you guys, and doing sketches, and doing challenges, and just, mixing it all into a really fun recipe.
It's been very hard to do because for one, we've been stockpiling a whole bunch of stuff because one,
I'm going to the UK, and then two, were all taking a big Christmas break, like, for two weeks.
I mean, the videos aren't gonna stop, but were still trying to stack them up, and keep them going, and also, at the same time, keep them interesting.
An-And thankfully, we have been doing that, and i'm really proud of the videos we've been making lately.
But, with Bob and Wade here, we also wanted to try new format stuff.
Which basically means, we wanted to try to do some improv games and most of what I do is improvisational comedy and some aspect or another like let's plays.
I'm making shit up as I go along. I don't have a script, it's not anything I've got predetermined in my head
And so, like, we love doing improv, and we love learning improv, so we actually took to trying to do improv
in our day to day life. So, I'm gonna show you some videos where it may work, you know?
Improv is a lot of hit or miss. Especially when you're doing it very free form and not very structured.
Um...
And especially when you don't have a game to talk about when you're doing it that can carry on the experience.
When you're just making bullshit up in your head, I mean, who know's what's gonna happen.
But... sometimes, it works and sometimes it doesn't and we're trying to figure out a way to make a good video about it
that's really funny because there's some really funny moments.
[Tyler]: Here's a dildo for your medical procedure Billy.
*giggling like a bunch of school girls*
[Bob]: I didn't ask for THAT!
*giggling*
[Bob]: I'm FINE!!
*Mark joins in on the giggles with a hearty gut laugh*
[Bob]: I'm TWELVE!!!!
[Ethan]: Change!
[Bob]: I just wanna be a GIRL!!!
[Laughter]
[Tyler]: Well, why do ya think that's the reason I got you this dildo?
[Bob]: No, I'd rather have the money!
[Bob]: The dildo doesn't make me grow any surgery?!?!?!?
[Ethan]: Change!
[Bob]: These are BOOBS!!!
[Ethan] Change!
[Bob]: Does this look like a girls ass to you?!?!?!
[Tyler]: I don't know. Can I touch it?
[Bob]: NO!!! ........  Still twelve......
[Bob]: That's illegal!
So, so, basically uh- the game that we are playing
is called "Change"
and you've probably seen it in "Who's Line is it Anyway" or whatever
if you've ever been to an improv show
it's short form improv
Basically, you're doing a scene, with two
random, made-up, bullshit characters
and then somebody can yell "change"
And, you have to come up with a new line
of dialogue
And, it, it, it, its REALLY
hit or miss. Because depending on what they
come up with is either absolutely
HILARIOUS or completely
fall flat on its face and,
Thankfully, like, e-each scene
is like, intermixed with just a
few of these elements and hopefully
there's enough to carry it through.
But without, like, the proper guidance
you know, you don't know if it can make a funny actual video.
So, it-it's equal parts funny
and equal parts cringey at times
but, it makes for a-a wholesome
experience, as some might say.
But I won't be a-it's not that.
[Mark]: SEE!? We are in the future MAN!!
[Mark]: TOTALLY!!! Dude, lets look up lottery ticket numbers
[Mark]: and then go back to the past and win them.
[Tyler]: Do they have that in Almanacs???
[Mark]: *whispering* What's an Almanac?
[Bob]: Change.
[Mark]: *whispering* What are YOU?!?
[Mark]: Oh my GOD! I forgot the OVEN!
[Mark]: IT'S ON, BACK HOME!
FUCK!!!
MY HOUSE IS ALREADY BURNED DOWN!
[Tyler]: Our house?!
[Mark]: THE WHOLE FRAT HOUSE!
[Tyler]: BUT MOM'S NILL -bwhoa
[Laughter]
[Mark]: Why's my mom at the frat house?
[Tyler]: Bro, it's OUR mom bro...
[Mark]: Okay, alright, wait.....no!
I forgot, we did this for a reason bruh!
We were gonna find out the answers to the math test before we GOT BACK!!!
[Bob]: Change.
[Mark]: We were gonna go to the future to see your dad, when he's DEAD!
[laughter]
[Mark]: We were gonna tha- we were gonna go to tha future so we could ch........
*whispering* assasinate HITLER!
[Mark laughs at himself]
[Tyler]: Dude!
YOU'RE TOTALLY RIGHT!
[Mark]: I KNOW!
We talk about this in our frat charter.
[Mark sings]: ~I will not molest the girls~
~Or the guys with really big boobs~
[laughter]
[continues singing]: ~I don't have any testicles left  to give youuuu~
[Mark laughs at himself again]
[Mark]: You know our theme song, man! You can't tug my tit!
[Mark]: We're here in the fu--      [Tyler]: Pew Pew!
Stop that! Just stop!
[Tyler]: But I like the way it sounds!       [Mark]: Don't! Just-
[Tyler]: It reminded me of what your mom sounded like last night!
[Mark]: WE HAVE THE SAME MOM!
[Tyler]: Oh yeah.       [Mark]: God DAMMIT, man!
[Mark]: Stop!!
Oh jeez... Oh jeez... Yeah.
So, you can see how... it's interesting in that, you know, we're not experts at improv by any stretch of the imagination.
We don't know what we're doing, and we're mostly just did this [sic] because
we wanted to learn, and we wanna practice and we wanna get better at this because, you know,
better improv skills lead to better, like, just comedy in general and make it for better videos in general.
So, we do these exercises, uh, so that we can, you know... practice!
But we don't know if it's actually gonna make a video. 'Cause there's really funny moments in there,
and then there's really not funny moments and it'd be kinda awkward to loose context on the whole scene
if we were cutting in between everything.
'Cause we only really have this one camera angle and there's not much you can do to cut it in between it but
maybe we could make something like a highlight reel out of the various videos that we've done.
Because, there's some really, really funny moments, like Bob had some unbelievably funny moments because
Bob, I've said numerous times, Bob is the funniest guy I have ever met in my entire life.
He is just the master of comedy in our circle. Like, everything he says in every way that he says it,
and we did a "Don't Laugh" challenge, and we were all floundering, but every time Bob came up
like, he was the master... [Mark hits his hand on the table]
AH FUCK!
Anyway, he was-he was just the master of making everybody laugh at  every opportunity.
And it was just so fun to watch! It was so fun to just watch Bob do it.
And that's part of the reason why I want to do these scenes, is because Bob was so funny!
[Lloyd] : I thought you wanted to have children, just like this plant is sprouting.
[Bob] : You know what you have to do to have children?
[Bob] : You have to FUCK, Lloyd.
[Everyone laughs]
[Bob] : If you want to have kids, take me home...
... and fuck me!
[Laughter ensues...]
[Mark] : And then we did one that was really funny, it was, it was another 'whose line' game
called literally "Whose Line?" Where we get bits of pieces of paper and if you may have noticed we tweeted out
and we asked for random sentences. This is what that was for!
And it was for, uh... [video starts, unintelligible]
it was for us...
[Lloyd] : [raspy voice] The darkness is consuming me
[Mark] : [raspy voice] I'm Tyler, and I once fisted a whole family of goats!
[Mark continues]: I'm Tyler! I'm gonna find some gold!
[Mark continues]: I'm Tyler! We're gonna fist some goats!
[Mark continues]: I'm Tyler! *unintelligible groaning*
I just love the way that particular joke uh, makes us laugh, and it was so cuh!
I-it was so cuh...
it was so
CUH!
It was so funny because, when we were doing "Quick, Draw!" there was this little girl there that literally went up to me
was like "Hey I have a joke!"
"I'm Tyler! And I have no legs!" [laughs] and she started doing the "I'm Tyler" joke!
"I'm Tyler!" which if you don't know, originated from the 7 Second Challenge when it devolved into absolute bullshit towards the end
but kinda in the best way. Like, my God, we love that video so much!
If you haven't seen that video, my God, go watch our most recent 7 Second Challenge because it was absolutely hilarious
especially at the end of the video.
Oh man.. And, uh, and it was just a lot of laughs like that because when you're doing improv with your friends,
it's so fun, but maybe you don't want anyone else to see it because you don't know if it's funny, but we're hoping to
build these skills so that we can create this group that we can take out and actually maybe do, like, a live improv show.
I don't know when we're gonna get the skills to be able to do that, like, uh, we're learning from, uh,
If you know Ninja Brian's wife, Rachel, she is an absolute master of improv. She's incredible.
She's been doing it for, like, eight years straight, and she's a professional teacher and I've seen her in live shows
and absolutely everything she says is hilarious. So we're learning from her, when she has spare time to do it.
And it's just so fun. And also, like, I wanted to mention that we did do a lot of let's plays just in general.
We got about seven of them done.We've got seven let's plays, We've got, like, seven challenges, and then five other miscellaneous videos
and more in case we actually make the improv stuff into something.
So, if you actually want to see the improv stuff, let us know down in the comments below
because, we want to do it.
And we wanna go out and do more things with you guys!
Maybe not even full meetups, but just going out into LA or taking road trips across the country
and just meeting you guys wherever we go.
And just recording videos about it. Making it something fun and interesting and always keeping stuff on hand
to be able to do stuff with you guys, and have fun and, like, that's what it's all about!
It's about new ideas and trying new things and being creative and meeting you guys and just having fun in a million ways, and making a video about it.
Like, that's what YouTube has always been to me. That's what it- I've always have driven me [sic] to do more stuff.
It's just this idea that I can make absolutely anything,
anything I wanted, and all it takes is the  smallest idea.
And I can turn that into something amazing.
And that's what's really cool. That was what was so fun about this past week.
And that's why I'm so excited to be able to show you guys about it because we're gonna be editing
for a long time on making these videos come to life, and it's gonna take a while to do it.
But when you see what we've accomplished here, it is going to be so, so, fun.
And I cannot wait for you guys to see it, but it is coming very soon. So I'll let you guys know when I leave for the UK and when I come back
I'll probably be documenting it all on social media, so check it out there.
There'll be pictures, videos, tweets, whatever have you.
I'll just keep you guys posted, and it should be fun, I believe the livestream is on Thursday... But I'm not 100% sure.
It may be on Friday, just stay up to date about that, and I'll let you know soon, or if you guys know the exact date
...I should know that! But all I know is I'm gonna show up in London and hopefully know where I'm going from there.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching! And as always, I will see you... In the next video!
Buh-bye!
Thanks for watching!